أعلن اليوم عن
خطوات إضافية لتصحيح
سياستنا الخارجية وتوحيد قيمنا الديمقراطية بشكل أفضل
مع قيادتنا الدبلوماسية للبدء ،
سيقود وزير الدفاع أوستن
مراجعة الموقف
العالمي لقواتنا بحيث تتوافق بصمتنا العسكرية
بشكل
مناسب مع خارجنا
سيتم تنسيق أولويات السياسة والأمن القومي عبر جميع
عناصر أمننا القومي
مع عمل الوزير أوستن والسكرتيرة
بلينكين بتعاون وثيق
، وأثناء إجراء هذه المراجعة ،
سنوقف
أي عمليات سحب مخطط لها للقوات من
ألمانيا ،
سنقوم أيضًا بالتصعيد  دبلوماسيتنا
لإنهاء الحرب في
اليمن حرب خلقت كارثة إنسانية واستراتيجية
لقد طلبت من فريقي في الشرق الأوسط ضمان
دعمنا للمبادرة التي تقودها الأمم المتحدة
لفرض وقف إطلاق النار
وتحدي إنساني مفتوح واستعادة
الخمول الطويل  محادثات السلام هذا الصباح
عين الوزير بلينكين تيم
إقراض
مهنة بولي في الخارج  ضابط الفضاء الإلكتروني بصفته مبعوثنا
الخاص
للصراع في اليمن وأنا
أقدر قيامه بهذا
الوقت لأن الحياة لديها خبرة مدى الحياة في
المنطقة وسيعمل مع مبعوث الأمم المتحدة وجميع
أطراف النزاع
للضغط من أجل حل دبلوماسي
ودبلوماسية تيم.  سيتم
تعزيزه من خلال
العمل الأمريكي المعتاد لضمان وصول المساعدات الإنسانية
للشعب
اليمني الذي يعاني من دمار غير قابل
للتحمل لا يمكن تحمله
يجب أن تنتهي هذه الحرب وتأكيد
التزامنا بإنهاء كل
الدعم الأمريكي
للعمليات الهجومية والحرب في اليمن
بما في ذلك  مبيعات الأسلحة ذات الصلة